moans in Belgium is putting itself on a
new map this time with the help of two
French artist from the theatre group X
TNT supporters of the project is to
create a map of mousse which will be a
European cultural capital early next
year so we're creating this map with a
Street View application so we are going
filming shooting 10 kilometers of the
streets with the inhabitants which is
very important in an artistic set a 360
degrees stop motion camera captures the
images the actors for this scene are all
local residents including the police
it's my town so for me it's important
and
and we are having fun so it's okie the
artists in charge of street review
specialize in attention-grabbing urban
actions these scenes represent a police
chase of sorts
once the action has been filmed the team
quickly moves on to the next
installation the director of the project
has a certain message in mind the idea
too is this this project was well one
day i was just googling my street in
multi close to paris and I was seeing
how ugly it was how ugly the people were
how looked like a phantom phantom city
and the more I looked into all these
streets the more I thought but who does
these streets belong to they belong to
the people we're playing with the people
we're getting the people to come down
the street and to express through
different concepts different ideas their
own feeling about how they should just
represent their city in a more playful
way playful indeed this action involves
leaving the office behind and getting
closer to nature the results are
somewhat surreal
the idea is to fill up the city and try
to get as much of the interesting parts
of the city so today we're gonna do a
lil of where the Bazar Museum of moles
is and the name of the museum is the BAM
the BAM will host three major
exhibitions next year including one by
Dutch artist Vincent van Gogh today's
urban action in front of the museum
involves two groups supporters of
classic artists like Bruegel and Renoir
and other famous names and those who
adore Andy Warhol what looks like a
confrontation is just an enthusiastic
expression for art
while some of the local residents
observe the action others seem confused
by what's going on
most will host some 300 projects as
European Capital of Culture main
destinations will be the ground class
the city's main square and the belfry
tower a World Heritage Site moans dates
back to the Middle Ages but many of the
current buildings were constructed
between the 15th and 17th centuries it's
an easygoing town steeped in history but
the city is eager to promote itself as a
place which also embraces modern life
back in front of the museum the street
view scenes are slowly gaining momentum
ludovic a former stage director has to
keep everyone focused on the action
filming goes late into the evening and
when it's over it will be on to the next
scene that will help months put its
stamp on European culture in 2015
you